and i'm the youth development director
for the ymca of southern nevada
okay and i saw online that the
centennial hills ymca is doing a team
program um the next one is coming up
this saturday tell me a little bit about
that program and uh what the purpose of
it is
yeah absolutely so in 2017 the
centennial hills neighborhood
experienced a rise in a teen crime and
teen mischief and so
organizations were coming to the y as
one of the leading providers of youth
development programming
in the nation to ask what services we
had
in response to this local need at the
time we had
our our teen summer day camp program
and we had a few volunteer opportunities
but we realized that in this moment we
needed to expand and that's exactly what
we did
we first created a teen internship
program within the summer day camp
program
and so summer campers within the teen
group
could interview for apply for and become
an intern and shadow under some of our
executives and directors
and at the end of their six-week journey
they were to pitch a program that the y
would consider launching and over the
course of the next couple of years the
teams pitched several programs that we
have
started like robotics and coding
programs and all sorts of really fun
things
but of course one of the things that
they really wanted to do was
more teen programs during the school
year and so we launched
over the last couple of years three new
teen programs and then we just launched
another one
late in the in the fall of 2020 so the
three
main school year team programs now are
team talks
teen connection and team night they
occur on the first and third saturday of
every month
uh they are there's a nominal fee for
our members and there's financial
assistance for those
who need additional support they're back
to back so teens usually get here
around one and then they get picked up
around nine which is what they
and their families found ideal the teen
talks program is really
uh heavily geared towards youth mental
health which is especially important
right now in pandemic times
with rising rates of youth depression
and unfortunately youth
suicides so teen talks partners which
with bridge counseling associates one of
the
premier nonprofit mental health
organizations here in southern nevada
they send out staff to lead structured
but open discussions on topics that the
teens
want to talk about so it's a safe space
for them to have productive
conversations on topics like
peer pressure and substance abuse and
yes even
depression and suicide then they move
into
the teen connection program right after
and team connection is all about
service learning and life skill
development so the teens engage
in a wide range of volunteerism projects
within the community
be that with the nevada
animal shelters with the
cancer organizations cancer groups
be that a whole bunch of different
projects after they combine
those service learning projects with
life skill development opportunities so
they get to learn from
those experiences out in the community
with animal shelters with cancer
organizations and then they mold them
into
lessons that they taught themselves to
inform future projects
and then they bring in outside parties
to teach them
more things so for example the teens a
couple years ago
said that they had they knew somebody
that was hearing impaired
up here and so they wanted to learn sign
language so we brought in somebody
and they spent one of their life skill
development days learning about sign
language
uh later on we have this session we have
somebody coming out
to teach them about money management and
financial literacy
and so they uh they get to do all these
really cool life skills development
projects
um throughout the session then they go
into team night which is all social
activities so we do things like
murder mystery nights uh disco nights
all sorts of these really fun
uh themed experiences where they get to
just kind of let loose
uh and be kids have fun yeah
wow this sounds like such a
comprehensive
program it really touches on so many
factors of a teenager's life and what
they're concerned about and what they
think is important
um i really like that you guys bring in
the teenagers to talk about these
programs what they want
how important is it to collaborate with
the youth in our area
absolutely it's especially important
youth voice and youth choice are
especially important especially
in these adolescent ages teens have
a lot of complacent options today right
they can stay home and they can play
video games
and many of them lately have been forced
to do that
they can just stick to their
neighborhood or
when they're left unsupervised because
parents have to work and can't afford
child care they're left to their own
volition and that's what caused
the rise in teen crime and mischief that
i talked about which launched these teen
programs
but to convince them to let go of these
other
more complacent opportunities and and
come to do something that's productive
something that develops
them into tomorrow's community leaders
requires that they are at the helm of
the decision-making process from
building the framework
all the way through execution and so
every component
of all of our team programs so i've
mentioned
three there are several others that we
have
the teens are at the helm from the very
beginning all the way
through they pick the topics for teen
talks they pick their service learning
projects they pick their
life skill development opportunities
they pick their themes for teen night
we have a program called the dreamer lab
in partnership with charlie rocket and
cox communications
at our heinrich facility in our durango
hills facility
those again are spaces where the teens
get
to decide how to create within them
so they come to these very very unique
spaces
and there are really qualified staff
that will guide them of course
but they're at the home of what they end
up wanting to
grow into that's so great and
for centennial hills for in terms of
that you know crime that was going on
with
the teenagers there why is that is it
because there wasn't
many options for them to you know it's a
growing community they're adding more
things to do but it was it because there
wasn't as much for teenagers to do out
there did you guys ever discuss
that yeah absolutely it's it's simply
because
of that that complacency factor there's
a a common
misconception that once my child is 12
13
they can stay home alone but
unfortunately their brain isn't fully
developed they're still relying on
instinctual behaviors right they're not
thinking through
their decisions from from a to z and so
it's very easy to get into
mischief and then from mischief it's
very easy to get into criminal behavior
and that's exactly what was happening
the
the wave was dubbed the caught on camera
crimes by teen's wave
so it was teams going to houses and
stealing amazon packages
throwing rocks at windows and and
it just evolved from that so again it's
it's this something that the y is
is constantly working on is promoting
the fact that the why
is a hub for youth and adults of all
ages
all abilities and especially all income
levels a common
barrier to accessing programs is that
financial barrier but
as a non-profit we eliminate that
barrier we will work with whatever
income you have to make sure we develop
either you or your child into the person
that reaches their full potential wow
and
for people that want to take part in
this for teenagers um
do they have to belong to the centennial
hills ymca how does that work
the cool thing about the y is uh we've
got four branches here in southern
nevada once you join one you're a member
of all of them
so there are lots of different programs
at all four of our centers
uh you join at one and you get access
to all of them a substantial amount of
them are free or nominal fee like the
teen programs
and then there are some that come with a
cost offset
so things like summer camp for example
comes with an additional cost
however of course what's extremely
important for uh for the y is that no
one will ever be turned away due to the
inability to pay
so you join based on your financial
circumstances and then you sign up for
the programs
uh based on your financial circumstances
we will take care of the rest
um that's really great especially in you
know what's going on right now with so
many people losing
their work and things like that um is
there anything else that you want to add
about the program anything i didn't ask
about that's important for parents and
their teenagers to know about the
about what's going on with you guys no i
think i think
you've done a great job touching base on
on some of these really important
programs
i'll say that
teens initially want to stay home
and stay within their comfort zone but
something that we learn even as adults
as you can't grow within your comfort
zone
so i would encourage parents to take a
look at the why
there's a lot of different programs
within teams you've got six or seven
different offerings
uh by themselves find the one or two
that fits
what you are hoping to get out of the
experience and then allow the y to
support you
uh from the financial assistance aspect
if if you need that assistance
and then if you're in the community and
you'd like to uh participate in these
programs we're always looking
for donors and volunteers to support and
grow this work